FEMALE SPEAKER: Today in
partnership with Zagat
we are privileged to
have Hugh Acheson.
Hugh Acheson is the
chef and partner
of four restaurants in Georgia,
5 & 10, The National, Empire
State South, and The Florence.
In 2010 Hugh competed on Bravo's
"Top Chef Masters" season
three, and he returned to
the hit show as a judge
starting in season nine.
Hugh won the James Beard
award for Best Chef Southeast
in 2012, and most recently he
released his third cookbook,
"The Broad Fork" which he'll be
showing us a couple of recipes
from today.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Hugh Acheson.
HUGH ACHESON: Bonjour.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGH ACHESON: So, I'm Canadian.
Hence is my denim on denim look
today, the Canadian tuxedo.
I am wearing khakis though, so
I didn't complete the outfit.
OK.
We're going to make two things.
Now this book is really
meant to be-- it literally
came about as an answer to
somebody down the street
when I was picking up my
CSA box in Athens, Georgia.
On this beautiful historic
street we live on,
walk down in a quintessentially
American moment,
you know, with my two daughters,
our hair flowing in the winds
and we pick up our
CSA box, because it's
supposed to be doing.
We're supposed to be cooking
from scratch, and its goodness.
And there was this one
annoying professorial guy,
because it's a college town
and they lurk on corners.
And he was like, what the
hell do I do with kohlrabi.
And he'd ask me questions
like this every week
and I was, like, dude, lay off.
It's just because I'm the mantle
of chefdom in Athens, Georgia.
They come to me and
ask me these questions
and it was ongoing and nonstop.
But it got me thinking
that nobody actually
knows what to do with kohlrobi.
And nobody knows what to do
with a lot of vegetables.
Or as Americans, in our
kitchens, we cook like this.
We cook the things we know, the
things that our parents taught
us, the things maybe our
grandparents taught us,
the things from our community,
the things from maybe
our heritage past, and those are
recipes we know and understand.
And we often don't
break them down,
even though we're
surrounded by great food,
and you guys eat out all
the time and eat great food.
Rarely do you go out and
actually try and cook
something new.
So it's meant to sort of pull
the blinders off, and just
cook four to five recipes
for one single ingredient.
So it goes through pretty much
the whole list of everything
I would have gotten in that
CSA box in a full year.
Some of the things you will not
experience, even in California.
Some of them you will
definitely experience.
If we were in Wisconsin
it would be different.
But here we are.
So first we're going to
do a really simple salad
with purslane, which
is either-- sometimes
it's farmed and
sometimes is foraged.
But it looks like this,
and it's a succulent.
And it's kind of got a
nice bitter sourness to it
as a green.
And then there's cantaloupe,
and there's prosciutto.
You could use really
good prosciutto de parma,
or you could use whatever fine
deli meats you could find.
In the salad we're going to
make a vinaigrette with that,
but starting off, we're
going to take a sweet onion.
And I've peeled
it, but you can see
that the core part of where
it was attached to the root,
and then immersed into the
ground and the greens--
the ground level would be right
here and the greens coming up.
This is where the
actual root stem was.
And that's going to keep it
kind of attached as we cut down.
So I peeled it and
then I'm just going
to cut down with a
pretty sharp knife,
and kind of keep them
together and that'll just
aid in the cookery of it.
So we're going to add a little
bit of butter to the pan.
This pans on medium
heat, because,
and I'm going to jack it up
just to sort of medium, medium.
Right now it's four, I'm
going to take it to five.
Sun does not go up to 11,
which is the "Spinal Tap"
reference for all of
you over 40 in the room.
Then we're going to take these,
and just put them in here
and it's a sensory thing,
it's a flavor thing,
but it's the best
smell that you'll ever
have in a kitchen, which is
onions cooking in butter.
So we're going to continue that,
just with a couple more slices.
Again this is-- you want to
work carefully with a knife,
but I know this sounds
contrary to logic,
but you want your knives
to be really sharp,
because the wound
will be a lot cleaner.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: So we're going
to process through some melon
as that cooks.
So what we're going to do,
is we're going to take this,
we're going to caramelize pretty
deeply, and for lack of time
I'm going to raise this
up seven out of ten.
Caramelize them pretty
deeply so they've
got a fair bit of color.
I'll add seasoning in the
form of a little bit of salt.
So salt is not a spice,
salt is a flavor extractor.
It pulls out liquid
from your palate,
it pulls out flavor
out of food, and you're
looking for that synergy
and maximization of the two.
And if you use too
much, it's gross.
So we're going to
take half of these
and puree them in a blender.
This is a Vitamix.
It can puree, you
look online and you
guys can laugh as they
puree apple products on it.
Then the other half
were going to reserve
the beauty of the salad
and it's integrity.
So we'll have beautiful
caramelized onions
dotting through that.
But the other half is
going to go in here.
It's going to get pureed with
some vinegar and some mustard,
and then mounted
with some olive oil
to create an
emulsified vinaigrette.
And meanwhile as that goes, let
me just pick this off to side,
and start on recipe
number two as we go.
I've got an oven under
here, and the oven,
said oven is at 400 right now.
I'm going to put this
on seven out of 10.
And we're going to get
some tomatoes roasting.
These tomatoes-- so you
want to work in seasons,
but if you want to
work with tomatoes
and you're not in the season of
summer, which is tomato season,
I would buy Roma tomatoes.
Because they're
inherently-- seem
to be the most stable and
consistent tomato out there.
They're not large
and mealy and weird.
And they actually can
concentrate their flavor really
well by doing what we're about
to do, which is roasting them.
So you're going to get rid
of a lot of the superfluous
liquid in them, in favor of
keeping the sugars behind.
So I'm just going
to cut off the top
and cut them down
lengthwise, and then we're
going to get them in
a pan and get them
slathered with just a
little bit of olive oil,
and some salt and pepper,
fresh thyme, and garlic.
This is thyme, right?
You bought the shaky thing
of thyme six years ago,
you should throw it away.
Herbs are leafy green things,
spices are barks and seeds.
They differ a lot, but both are
essential oils-- are contained
in them that give us
the flavor, but if they
sit around and dry out, they
don't have as much flavor.
There are definitely some
uses for dried herbs,
don't get me wrong,
but not many.
And spices go stale
as well, so you
got excited about taco
night eight years ago,
the cumin is probably--
it's time to move on.
So buy spices in small amounts,
and get rid of them or motor
through them often.
This is a clove
of peeled garlic,
if you buy pre-minced
garlic, you are dead to me.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: Good.
Moving on.
We're going to discard this,
that's the good garbage.
That's the bad garbage.
I'm going to put just a little
bit of olive oil in the pan,
and then we're going
to put these in.
Just skin side u-- or the
cut side up, skin side down,
and then we're
going to season just
with a little bit of
salt. I use kosher salt.
What kind of kosher salt
is this, diamond crystal?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yep.
HUGH ACHESON: So,
diamond crystal
is the one we all use
in restaurants, it just
feels right.
It's dorky, but if you use
another type-- and salt differs
a lot, if you take
Morton's kosher salt,
and weigh the amount that
it takes to be a gram,
is far different
from diamond crystal.
So it just helps to get
a solid reference point.
So the fresh thyme is
going to go in there,
and then I'm going to slather
them with a lot of olive oil.
The thyme's really just
going to flavor it out,
so I want to beat it up as
I'm sticking it in there.
I'm looking over at these,
and they're not burning,
they're doing what they're
supposed to be doing.
And anyhow, in the modern
school of cheffery,
burning stuff is cool.
So it's like,
everything's charred now.
It's like, wow, who
got really lazy?
I'm going to put a lot of
olive oil over the top of them.
That's just going to
give it a lot of flavor.
And I'm going to bring that up--
going to bring the pan up hot.
Normally you could just take it
a pan that's room temperature
and get them in the oven.
I'm just aiding
this because it's
a longer process than the
30 hours of quality time
we have together.
Into the oven we go.
And let's go back--
what are you doing?
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: OK.
Nobody saw that Hugh,
everything's fine.
I'm going to check on these.
They're doing what
they're supposed to do.
Now did you notice the one
of things I'm not doing
is-- cooking is a matter of
paying attention to the stove,
but you do not have to be
doing this all the time.
I don't know why, my wife
is always like-- I'm, like,
what you're doing?
So just let it go.
It's caramelizing,
it's doing its thing,
just let it mellow
out and enjoy the time
you're having with your onions.
I just turned it down to five.
If you don't have a numeric
system on your stove
you are not going to
learn anything today.
So on top of all
this, you're going
to have to buy a new stove.
This is going to be a really
expensive free demonstration
and a $10 book.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: This is a melon.
It is a cantaloupe.
It's season is just beginning,
if we were in south Georgia,
north Florida we would
see them right now.
I'm just going to cut down.
And any fruit, if you're
making orange supremes,
it's the same
thing, you're trying
to create a flat
surface by cutting off
the top and the bottom.
And then you're
going around on it
pretending like
you're cutting off
the outer layer of the globe.
Civilization is
doing that by itself,
but we're going to do this
well-- So all the way down,
and I'm going to circle
around, sometimes
you miss a little nubbin on
the bottom, but I nailed it.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: Down--
I'm not, yeah I am.
Then I'm going to scoop out the
center seeds, just carefully
and that's about it.
So let's talk about
convenience items in stores
and what you're doing wrong.
If you go and buy
cubed cantaloupe
you're paying somebody
to do a lot of the work,
you understand that, right?
And I'm not saying
your time is not
more important than
cubing cantaloupe,
but if you buy crumbled
feta, what is wrong with you?
Have you ever tried
to crumble feta?
It is not very challenging.
Like it just literally
crumbles within your fingers.
Yet, it is a commodity product.
That is amazing to me.
I'm going to cut
some slices of this.
You guys are like,
this guy is weird.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: First question.
HUGH ACHESON: First question.
AUDIENCE: How do you
identify a ripe cantaloupe?
HUGH ACHESON: Smell it,
aromatically it should
it smell ripe.
It shouldn't be soft at all, but
it should have firmness to it,
but not be rock solid.
If you hear sloshing inside,
it means that it's probably
weirdly ripe inside.
So trust your gut, or you
find, like Curtis Stone
in a grocery store.
Do you remember
that show he used
to do, where he used to accost
women in the grocery store,
and take them home and
cool at their apartment.
It was really weird store.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: Totally
illegal in most states,
but he's tall and Australian
and beautiful, so--
I flip these over,
they look like that.
Can you see that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HUGH ACHESON: Mike, too?
How are you doing?
That's Mike two.
I'm just going to slice this
down into pieces that we're
going to use in our salad.
So just nice little
thin slivers.
And we're going to
fold them around
and we'll go through
making the salad.
Come on in.
Yeah, what's up with that?
Oh, is it because
the metals on there?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes, it doesn't
like that the spatula is--
HUGH ACHESON: So this
is an induction burner,
which in chefdom, they're
really frustrating devices.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Back at eight?
HUGH ACHESON: No, you're good.
Let's go to four.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Got it.
HUGH ACHESON: Thank you.
So the purslane is one
of my major elements
in this, it could be arugula,
it could be, if any of you
you are into
foraging, it could be
a bunch of different
cresses right now,
that are in the marketplace.
You can-- Where did you
guys buy this purslane?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Through
one of our vendors--
HUGH ACHESON: Nice.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
HUGH ACHESON: OK.
So that's pretty much done.
We're just going
to turn that off
and just going to let that
mellow out just a little bit.
So I'm just picking through,
going to pick the leaves off.
Literally-- and back to the herb
thing, in California or where
I'm from in Georgia,
if you can't grow mint,
you can't grow anything.
So move into a condo,
and call it a day.
Because mint is a weed.
And so you should probably just
grow it, and then you can--
I'm going to send my
kids to college on mint.
I'm going to make them sell it.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: So this is-- we're
just going through and picking
some of the bigger
stocks off these
and getting the nice
pieces, and avoiding
the ones that aren't so nice.
But purslane is really cool.
You could use frisee in
this if you wanted to.
I'm big into bitter
greens right now, frisee,
and radicchio's, and triveso's,
and all those Italian ones.
So we're motoring through that.
We're going to make our
vinaigrette in a second,
and then we're going to jump
back to cooking with fennel,
because nobody knows what
to do with fennel either.
So I'll talk through
fennel overall.
So this recipe is appearing
in the cantaloupe section,
but it could just as well
appear in the purslane section.
There actually really
isn't a purslane section,
but purslane does appear
in the book a lot.
Because I've got
one waiter who's
been with me very,
very long time,
who grows a lot
of purslane, Paul.
AUDIENCE: Paul--
HUGH ACHESON: So we're
going to take these
and we're going to use half of
them in the beautiful salad,
and half of them are
going to get pureed.
So this is the
mortem moment that we
cull the population
for the beautiful ones,
and they stay out, and the
other one gets blended up.
It's very strange totalitarian
regime of cooking.
That's going in there.
And then some
vinegar is going in.
So if you make a vinaigrette.
What's a vinaigrette?
Vinaigrette is a
ratio, it's 3:1.
Three to one what?
Well, three to one oils,
and often olive oil,
but it could be safflower
oil, or sunflower oil,
or a salad oil, depending
on what type of flavors
you want to bring to it.
And then the one, is
the vinegar or acid.
So that could be a
combination of citrus juices
or any vinegars.
And the balance is the
most basic vinaigrette
you'll ever make.
As you add other
things like the onions,
you're not really
changing that ratio,
you're just adding more
flavor components to it.
So with simple
ratios like that, you
can make life much
more convenient
because you've now just avoided
an entire aisle in the grocery
store.
So that's the way
cooking from scratch
should work and make
you think about things.
I have two kids,
Beatrice is 13 now,
but when she went off to
kindergarten when she was five,
I remember hearing this
kerfuffle in the kitchen
at 6 o'clock in the morning.
And she was making a
vinaigrette in a Mason jar.
Because that's how
we make them at home,
is just put everything into
a mason jar and shake it.
And she had made
this salad to go,
and she's standing on her
stool, making all this stuff
and it's 6 o'clock in the
morning, she's climbing around
and made a mess.
But for you, she made her
own stuff to go to school,
now she's like uh-nun,
because she's 13
and that's what they do.
I'm going to add a little
bit of salt to this,
and then we're going
to start pureeing.
Basically, in the
emulsification process
you want to add this in
relatively thin, or slowly.
If you add it in
really slow, you're
going to make a
onion mayonnaise,
so don't go too slowly.
And if you need to balance
the thickness of it,
you can stop and
add more vinegar.
You can also thin with water.
[BLENDER MOTOR]
HUGH ACHESON: And don't
be afraid to taste things
as you're going along.
This looks compostable?
Nice.
You guys, as a uniform
team, you're like yes.
Go green.
So that is pretty much
done, the end result
is looking like this.
We just made a really
simple vinaigrette
in a matter of moments and it's
really not that hard to do.
Because it's got that
roasted allium flavor, which
is the onion, it's really
got a ton of flavor to it,
so it's pretty versatile.
It'll keep in the fridge,
for five, six seven days.
There's not really
much perishable,
other than the butter and the
onion that was cooked in there,
so the other things-- I
mean obviously the oil
is perishable, but it
takes a much longer time
for that to go to a bad point.
So when we say it'll say good,
it'll stay good in the fridge
obviously.
So let's take all the
other elements to it
and lay them aside, and
we'll build our salad later.
And let's go through
right now and we'll just
start the other elements
for the fennel salad.
So the fennel salad is
a salad with fennel.
So that's a whole
bulb of fennel.
And then it's
got-- hold on and I
need to put my garlic
in with my tomatoes.
You're like man,
amateur, this guy.
We're just going to throw this
in with the-- it'll probably
be a good time.
How are you?
You're doing pretty good.
Here we go.
And it's got anchovies it in.
Usually they would be
Spanish white anchovies.
These are Italian salted
anchovies, which are flat guys,
so we're just going to
rinse them quite well, quite
aggressively in cold water.
And then pat them dry
and then fold them
into a salad at the end.
In this, we're going to shave
the fennel by cutting off
the main bulb part.
We're going to cut in
half and lightly core it.
So I'm going to-- and
then we're going--
I saved some of the frond.
Don't throw these away
because either they're
going to go into
your chicken stock,
or you're going to dutifully
mince them and make them
into a pickled chow chow.
But y'all are busy, so maybe
just the stock, or hell.
The compost pile.
I don't know, whatever you want
to do, you're in your kitchen,
I'm not following you
home, like Curtis Stone
in that creepy show.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm clipping
the end off where
its root was attached to
it, and it was in the soil.
And then if we see here,
this is the core part
that is a little
firmer, so I'm just
going to make a little v cut on
that, and cut off some of that.
Leaving still enough of it--
it's just like the onion,
to hold it together.
Then we're going
to take a Benriner,
a lot of you guys work with
your fingers and typing,
so you don't-- You could use
a knife for this if you want,
but this is a
Japanese mandoline,
and they're really
ballistically sharp.
They probably account for
more cuts in the kitchen
than pretty much anything.
And what we're
doing is, we're just
going to slice it pretty thinly.
I'm actually going to go just
a little bit thinner than that.
But it does come with a
guard that will protect you,
but it will take
like three hours
to make what you want to
make, so I don't use it.
But also, like when we
come to a certain point
to keep the integrity
of our fingers--
and God, when these
things, when they cut,
they just so cleanly
and beautifully cut,
and you're bleeding
everywhere, it's great.
But it results in
this, and at the speed
that I did that, it would
take a long time for you
to do with a knife,
so it's very fast.
So your comfort,
leisure level, I
do not want you
to cut yourselves.
That's going to go to the side.
I'm going to do a
little bit more on that.
I hear [INAUDIBLE],
are you like,
did he sign that release form?
Can I see it?
We can get a new copy of that?
Hugh?
I'm not going all the way down.
Safety first.
And then that's going
to get scooped up
and put in this dish.
What we want to do
at this point is
kind of get it
macerating a little bit.
So macerating is administering
something like an acid, or even
a sugar if it was berries
or something like that.
In this case, it's going to
be just fresh lemon juice.
If you buy the
plastic lemon, that
says it's real lemon with
the little copyright symbol,
you are also dead to me,
so this is just going over.
Also to help with the
maceration in the process
is going to be just
a little bit of salt,
and then just a little
bit of olive oil.
And I'm just going to take
really fancy culinary tweezers,
and mix them.
Culinary tweezers,
these were given
to be by Albert Adria who
is Ferran's brother, which
if you ever go to Barcelona
he has an amazing restaurant,
called Tickets, and just
opened up another one.
And gave them to me, he's
just bestowed them on me,
I was very excited, and then
I realized that tweezers are
a lot cheaper at the pet store.
They're for de-worming,
but they are literally
the exact same things, and
they cost $2 versus $25
at Sur La Table, and I'm
like, man what a racket.
So that's going to set aside.
I'm going to take this little
bit of frond that I've got,
which is the top leafy green.
I'm just going to
tear it through,
and that's going to give
a nice little bit of color
to our end results.
And again this is
two salads, but I
think the modern realm
of how we eat in America
has totally changed.
And it's no longer a
meat and potatoes world,
so if you had this and some
roasted tofu next to it
and some brown rice and maybe
another little salad element,
to me that's dinner.
We all work a lot, we all do
a lot of stuff, we work out,
we're always running around
and you want to feel good.
And a 12 ounce steak
or a massive thing
is just not feel good food,
it's once a month food now.
It still exists, and I still
want it, not too often.
Ate at Mourad last
night, it was good.
That's that new Moroccan, I
just wish it was more Moroccan,
but I'll write them a
Yelp review, don't worry.
I have like 25 Yelp accounts.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: Retribution.
So again, this is going
with those roasted tomatoes
that we've got in the oven,
and these anchovies which
we're just going to rinse
pretty vigorously, in the oven.
How are you?
What's going on?
Nothing?
[HUMMING]
So obviously anchovies
are preserved in salt,
so if you don't rinse
them, then people are like,
yeah, I don't like anchovies,
they're really salty,
and you're like, well
yeah, that's because you
didn't rinse them.
But you can buy bigger salt
packed anchovies from Italy,
you can buy the ones like these,
which are salt packed and then
packed in oil, or you can
buy Spanish boquerones, which
are again curated in
salt, but then marinated
in vinegar and olive
oil, and are delicious.
Delicious.
What am I doing?
I'm going to look in the oven.
Seven minutes, 55 seconds.
That's a hot oven.
Remember that day you
burned down Google Hugh?
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: It's hard to
forget that one, honestly.
The tomatoes look like that.
The garlic went in
at a perfect time.
It is browned but not burnt,
it is quintessentially done.
It is exactly what
I wanted, and I hope
it's what you will like to.
We're going to plate this
puppy up and get this going.
I'm going to take this bowl, and
I'm going to take the fennel,
and put it in there.
I'm going to put
the anch-- hold on.
Thinking.
Plating is however you
want, you know, it's like,
but that's what we do now.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: It's minimalist.
It's small.
Your 26 other courses
will be coming out soon.
But this is at home so I'm
going to actually plate it
like somebody would
actually want to eat it.
So we're just going to
lay some of this out.
I think that food should be--
have almost like a 3D-ness
to it.
And be pretty and look
good, but not overwrought.
I don't think you
need to-- you guys
know the Japanese
concept of wabi-sabi?
Sort of elegant disarray,
I kind of work with that.
Meaning if somebody
doesn't like it,
you can just stand back
like a Japanese master,
going whatever, you
don't understand my art.
[HUMMING]
I don't know why I'm
doing one of the NPR
songs as my humming
thing, but-- [HUMMING]
And then the anchovies
are going to go over.
I'm going to get a little bit
more of that frond in there.
I'm going to add just a little
bit of olive oil to this too.
If you wanted to,
like if this-- there's
another part of the book that's
got pickled shrimp in it,
and if you wanted to make
a batch of pickled shrimp
and then tuck them into
this as a beautiful side.
And this is meant
as a spread, this
is again-- it's reactionary
cooking to the farmer's market
and what's there.
So it you had other
things in-- I'm just
trying to take the blinders off
and expand the horizons of what
you're thinking about-- is
cooking at home with food
and also making you realize it's
really not as difficult as most
people make it seem.
We have a vested interest
in you guys still coming
to restaurants
obviously, because it's
how I pay my mortgage.
But I want you to
cook at home, I
want you to realize
that cooking is easy,
but I don't know-- none
of you probably have kids,
you're tech people.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How
many of us have kids?
HUGH ACHESON: How many of
you-- do you have kids-- Nice.
Nice.
AUDIENCE: Grandkids.
HUGH ACHESON: You know,
I mean, grandkids?
That's awesome,
what are you, 40?
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: I think
the important thing is,
the best time you'll ever
have in your life if you
are a parent is
cooking with your kids,
because it's multi-fold.
You're teaching
them life skills.
Because at 20 years old,
you remember, all remember,
how hard it was.
You're on your own,
you're eating crappy food,
you miss the Happy Meal, but
they won't sell to you anymore.
This idea of how to feed
ourselves, and life skills,
and surround ourselves with
basic cooking things, this food
is not expensive to make at all.
But it's good food and if I can
teach my kids, like Beatrice,
again shaking it, at five
years old making vinaigrette.
If I could teach her also
how to scramble an egg,
and make a perfect omelette,
and make a simple soup,
and roasted chicken, I'm done.
I gave her enough that she can
feed her and her six friends,
or her and her three families if
she starts having babies soon,
she's going to be in
deep shit if she does.
But this is the idea.
To me, I live in a
community, it ain't my kids,
it's everybody's kids
who are around me,
and if you then take
the circles of community
and make them bigger,
it's everywhere.
We've got a duty to make sure
that the next generation has
much more endowed life
skills than we do.
So that's the important thing.
Let's plate up this other one.
This is again beautiful--
the beautiful onions,
this is the prosciutto,
so I'm going
to get a little
bit of that down,
and I'm going to take some of
my purslane and my vinaigrette.
I'm going to just put the
dressing on at the very top,
because I don't want to wilt
this purslane down too much.
And then the onions go
in, and I'm just going
to layer another bit of this.
This is pretty-- you don't
have to have a fancy meat
slicer at home.
There's batting cage
though, out back,
so there's probably a
really nice meat slicer
you can borrow somewhere.
Sergey was like, we
need meat slicers,
we're doing a whole
room of meat slicers.
Then I'm just kind
of repeating this
and then the onions
are going on.
The onions are so pretty
though, and onions to me
are awesome flavor because
they're cooked sugar.
Onions are the way that
everybody's like, how do I get
at my kids to eat vegetables?
I'm like, feed them cooked
onions and beets when they're
two years old, they'll
never know what candy is,
because it's got so much
sugar in there already.
So that's getting
tucked in there.
If you serve this with a
really good loaf of bread,
you're just expanding the
idea of what dinner is.
Hold on one second, I'm
going to dress this.
Look at that, I have one
minute and 54 seconds.
[FAUCET RUNNING]
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: You guys
are like, this guy's good.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: Thank you.
The vinaigrette is
really beautiful,
it's got a puckeriness.
I go on the side of--
I enjoy acid in food,
I enjoy brightness in food.
I like that flavor.
I think it's sort of bouncy to
me, and redolent and exciting.
I don't like uber rich
flavors, so the vinaigrette
is probably more on the acidic
side than a lot of people
are used to.
We have a minute and 15
seconds for questions.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: What about
the cantaloupe?
HUGH ACHESON: OK.
Aa-- Aa-- Aa-- Aa-- Shit.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: And the cantaloupe
goes on, beautifully arranged,
just like that.
It helps to have somebody
remind you about it,
before you get embarrassed
in front of a crowd.
OK.
Nice.
OK, beautiful, perfect, OK.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGH ACHESON: Anybody
have any real questions?
That was a statement,
not a question.
You can ask me questions,
I'm turning this off.
Off.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What do you like
to cook for your kids?
Or what do they get really
excited about if you're
cooking?
HUGH ACHESON: Steak.
But, you know, to me it's
like two big rib-eyes
for the four of
us, that probably
amount to four ounces
of meat per person.
And I cook them on
this little tiny--
I've got this-- what's
called a-- what's it called?
A lodge, like
outdoors-man grill,
but it's just like this
little tiny cast iron,
all cast iron grill,
that is awesomely cool,
and fun, and inexpensive.
But then next to it is
three different salads
like this, and wheat berries,
or they're big fans of farro.
And it's just a spread, and
oftentimes we eat family style,
so I'll just line up
six platters of stuff
and we'll have-- sit
around the counter,
and we'll have
four empty plates,
and we'll just plate it up.
As a parent I've found
that kids eat really well,
this is going to put
a lot of light bulbs
above peoples heads,
but when they're hungry.
So if they have a 5:30 snack,
and you're eating at 6:30,
they're probably
not really hungry,
and that's when you see the
vegetable pushing game off
to the sides.
So you got to make them
hungry, so don't feed them.
Now, I mean, just don't feed
them a bunch of crap at 5:30
and you're going
to have a better
chance of feeding them well.
But they eat anything.
If I roast them a chicken,
and Carolina gold rice,
and old school country
gravy, and then next to that
is escarole, and beets, and
roasted carrots, and peas,
they'll eat all of that.
Which is good, which is
good, they're healthy kids.
AUDIENCE: So besides
de-worming tweezers,
what is your favorite
kitchen instrument and why?
HUGH ACHESON: Probably spoons.
I mean, I know it sounds
dorky, but we use spoons a lot.
But we use them as spatulas, we
use them as everything a lot.
They're versatile,
but these are bigger
than your standard spoons--
this one's also slotted.
They're called
Kunz spoons, but it
was designed by a guy
named Gary Kunz, who's
a really famous
chef in New York.
He was the chef at
Lespinasse at one time.
But, whatever.
And I like a Vitamix blender.
They're just really
powerful blenders.
They're really handy for making
smoothies in the morning,
and making vinaigrettes,
they make soups, and purees,
and all that sort of stuff.
So, they're good.
I think investing in
good pans is good.
But you don't necessarily
have to spend a lot of money,
if you don't want to spend
a lot of money on pans.
Buy cast iron, but you
have to take care of it.
And you have to watch a YouTube
tutorial, which one of you
probably has edited
somewhere along the line,
on taking care and
refinishing cast iron pans,
because it's a lot different
than what your grandmother told
you.
She was generally wrong.
What else?
Yes
AUDIENCE: Hey Hugh,
thanks for coming out.
HUGH ACHESON: Thanks
for having me.
AUDIENCE: What is the
first recipe we should all
try from "Broad Fork"?
HUGH ACHESON: Hum, you're
in spring right now.
If there's still
asparagus in the market,
there's an asparagus with
piperade, poached eggs
and grits.
Which you could do polenta or
whatever instead of the grits,
if you can't find them out here.
That's great and really simple,
and really straightforward,
that resonates with
spring, it also
resonates with--
you guys probably
don't have much time
off, but maybe you
could do that on Sunday
morning, so Yeah.
I'm thinking about you.
AUDIENCE: What's your go to
anchovy brand these days?
HUGH ACHESON: Go to anchovy
brand, hum, I don't know.
We buy really-- large
things, we cure our own too,
so I don't know.
I mean, I've had great success
with buying Spanish products
on Amazon.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: I mean I
live in Athens, Georgia,
I don't have many options.
But I get a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] canned tuna
and stuff like that,
I find it cheapest
there, so try one of those.
I mean look for Delician brand.
One of those ones,
would be good.
AUDIENCE: Your first book
won a James Beard award.
HUGH ACHESON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I'm
wondering about the role
of writing in your life.
I know you said earlier that
you do quite a bit of writing
and if this creative pursuit
and that one sort of mesh
together and--
HUGH ACHESON: I
think they do, yeah.
I never really-- somebody was
like, you should do a cookbook,
and I was like OK.
I was like, man, that will be
easy, I've got all the recipes,
and then you have nothing.
You really don't.
I mean I've got-- I have systems
of telling people what to do
and basic recipes
for restaurants.
I don't have anything
for home cooks.
So when you're writing
for a home cook,
literally I get
emails saying, you
know it said crack four
eggs, and used four eggs,
but you didn't tell me
to remove the shells.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGH ACHESON: So
it's not like I'm
saying I have to be
instructing people
that know absolutely nothing,
but it's very wide spectrum.
But I like writing, I'm
not very good at it.
I dropped out of college.
I come from a really
super academic family,
and I was the black sheep.
But I like it, and
it sort of tests me
and drives me to do it more.
And I think the only way you get
good at writing is by writing.
And you write and write
and rewrite and write,
and you just have to do it.
So you tell stories,
and narrative,
and anecdotes about
food in an attempt
to get people to
fully understand what
you're trying to get across.
The how to on recipes is
the most difficult thing.
It can be easy.
But if it's easy it usually
doesn't really fully explain
what you're having somebody do.
And it's really hard.
If every cookbook was animated,
with a little animated
button off to the side, that
would be great, but it's not.
Hold on.
Google is not on fire,
there's just a little--
FEMALE SPEAKER:
We've got one more.
AUDIENCE: I have an issue
where vegetables go bad.
Like I'll buy a ton at once.
What are good staple veggies or
the most versatile vegetables
to have.
HUGH ACHESON: Carrots.
People buy a lot
more than they need,
but buying really small amounts
is crazy stupid expensive
sometimes.
Now there's those
groups like Blue Apron,
and all these little
prep companies that
deliver you a stupid
prepped-- and I
don't want you to do that,
it's just silly and overpriced,
but, if one of your spouses
owns that company, I'm sorry.
I think that staples
in my fridge,
that aren't going to
go bad very quickly,
are going to be carrots,
onions, celery, obviously, these
are main core of a lot of
French cooking, fennel.
I usually always have button
mushrooms, or something
as simple button mushrooms,
and then the rest of it
is from the market-- and from
the farmer's market on Saturday
I buy some things.
How you store it is
really important.
Ziploc bags with a
moist paper towel
inside is going to keep
lettuces a lot longer, arugula
a lot longer, than just
standard shoving them
in the regular part fridge.
The crisper drawer
is there for a reason
though, it's kind of a
humidity controlled area.
And will keep things from
drying out more than anything.
So I'm trying to think
what other vegetables.
I mean obviously,
root vegetables
are going to have a
long time to them.
Any leafy frilly stuff
you just have to use.
But that's the other thing,
if you buy something,
it's the way we
consume anything,
if you don't have a real
purpose for it, don't buy it.
You need to be thinking
about what you're doing.
But that's the challenge
of the CSA boxes,
that you get the stuff and
you don't have a choice.
So you better love lettuce.
AUDIENCE: I heard
through the rumor mill,
actually I read
an online article,
that you're opening a coffee
bar in Ponce City Market--
HUGH ACHESON: I am.
AUDIENCE: which is super cool.
So I was just wondering
what drove you to--
HUGH ACHESON: I heard
through the rumor mill
that you guys are opening up
an office there, is that true?
AUDIENCE: Maybe, maybe not.
Unconfirmed.
HUGH ACHESON: Unconfirmed.
AUDIENCE: But I'd love
to hear about that.
HUGH ACHESON: So, I guess
when I opened up Empire State
South, which is a real
big restaurant in Atlanta,
I was like, man, a lot of
people are doing restaurants.
This was five years ago and
mixology was becoming the thing
again and whatever,
but I kept thinking,
you know a lot of
people aren't really
doing the bookends of a meal.
They're not really
paying attention
to great beverage program at
the beginning of your meal,
when you sit down
before you get food,
and then they're definitely
not thinking about coffee,
because they don't care
about coffee, because coffee
doesn't make them any money.
So I was like, well,
I care about coffee,
because I love coffee.
And I was like, what if we
did a really elaborate, really
good coffee program.
So we put one in Empire, and
it was a really big success.
It probably doesn't make
that much money still,
but it's been worth it and
it's gathered a lot of acclaim.
I have one guy there
named Dale Donchey.
And Dale's in this wonderful
world of third rail coffee,
and third rail restaurants,
and all this DIY culture.
It's just a lot of people
nerding out on single topics,
and Dale's just this
classic coffee nerd,
and he just knows
a ton about coffee.
And he's a great guy.
He's a really good leader.
So he and I are
starting a restaurant,
which is a massive kiosk.
I'm trying to think
what else wa-- oh, I
went to-- what was that
coffee shop I was at
in LA-- Sightglass.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sightglass.
HUGH ACHESON: Sightglass.
--the other day.
It's kind of like that set
up, but if I didn't own
everything else in the room.
So it's just an island, and
it's called Spiller Park, which
is the old name of the Atlanta
Crackers Baseball Team Stadium
that was on the site of
where Ponce City Market is.
So it'll be open-- it's a
multi roaster company, until we
start roasting our
own beans, which
is about a year and a half.
So we'll be using Four Barrel,
and there's roasters out here
we love, but there are a lot
of Canadian roasters we love.
Who's a coffee nerd
in here, anybody?
49th parallel, which
is great, which
is from Vancouver, Phil
and Sebastian from Calgary,
Four Barrel Heart from Portland,
couple others, George Howell.
So, yeah, we're excited.
That'll be open in--
So Ponce City Market, is
the second largest brick
edifice in North America, and
it's the old Atlanta City Hall
East, and before that was
the Sears distribution
center in Atlanta.
It's this amazingly massive
building, that's very complex
and a lot of tech
companies and other stuff
are moving in there,
MailChimp's in there,
a bunch of other
groups, but then there's
an elaborate retail level
with anthropology and crap
like that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank
you so much for coming.
Round of Applause.
[APPLAUSE]